dancy nor is a former advisor to Speaker
Paul Ryan he has spoken with Republican
members of Congress in the room during
the Oval Office meeting he was also a
senior adviser to Mitt Romney in the
2012 presidential campaign morning Dan
morning guys
so you've spoken to people in the room
we now have I guess two different
accounts or and you now have senators
saying other is saying basically you
have two Republican senators saying dick
Durbin is not telling the truth right
what's going on here look what it sounds
to me and obviously I was in the room
but what I'm trying to piece together
his Trump did say something derogatory
but it wasn't a big moment in the room
it's not like people stormed out it's
not like people interrupted him I mean
Lindsey made that Lindsey Graham made
that one comment but it wasn't sort of a
games game changing moment in the room
it seems like the politics burst out of
this meeting
about a day later what the concern is
forget leave aside that word that
everybody was repeating last week the
concern is that the president views the
world this way and views people based on
the group they come from and of course
people noted that the country's he made
note of all had people with different
colors skinned in Norway the one he
raised up has essentially an all-white
population look assuming he said a
version of what he said it's hugely
problematic because it basically makes a
sweeping judgment about people from
certain parts of the world even though
they're many talented people countries
by the way some of those countries may
be basket cases it's okay to say that
but doesn't mean that the talent coming
from those countries are basket cases
and it also has implications for our our
country's bilateral relationships with
the governments from those countries
that said there is a point to be made
that the immigration restriction Estela
jit iment argument some of us may
disagree with it but a legitimate
argument about the implications of this
lottery system that picks people from
certain countries designate certain
countries rather than a skills-based
mayor based immigration system like
Australia has like Canada has many
immigration reforms in this country are
pushing for that kind of system if
that's the point the president's trying
to make let's just say it was an
artifact it's so unfortunate to me Dan
that it now seems everybody's parsing
their words exactly what he said what he
didn't say but all right let's move on
from that where do we go now from here
because we still have the daka
conversation where does that leave that
discussion well I think two things are
gonna happen this
we Republican members I speak you think
they will now move to a temporary
spending bill sometime this week which
will get it to like third week of
February so basically punt which takes
down the threat of a government shutdown
so I do not think there'll be a
government shutdown this week I also
think based on the members I spoke to it
is unlikely they're gonna get a doc a
deal anytime soon because to blow up
from this meeting has raised the stakes
if Trump said something is that Senator
Durbin said that was vile racist and
hateful
how does now Senator Durbin sit down and
negotiate with the president who he
thinks is vile racist and hateful and
make any concessions if you're the
president how do you negotiate with
someone who has called you racist vile
and hateful I mean how do you make
concessions to that person both both
sides have a have a base problem now
once the president has a little bit of
an advantage here and that his
constituency
I don't think carrots if they get a doc
a deal he can walk away the Democrats
are not going to shut down the
government over daca let me ask you one
question about your good friend Mitt
Romney reports that he is in fact going
to be running in it in the state of Utah
can you confirm that I cannot confirm it
I'm not here it's a spokesman for it but
I think it is highly likely that he's
gonna move forward he have you talked to
him I have spoken to him yes and you
think it's highly laughing its
highlights no I'm gonna take that as a
yes no no we know that he is in good
health right now yes yes very good news
all right good health and senior